shaq's a very unique player in nba
history he's the first
player in nba history to have his shoe
size iq and jersey all be the same
number
man you look good you look good
congratulations you're you're uh your
knuckles of scrape did you walk here
[Applause]
i just happened to have from hal galema
the box scores chuck
56 dominique 50
uh against detroit uh i like that can i
get that let it go man
50 point games how many how many did you
just have one no check you have you have
one how many you got to shoot for how
many 50 point playoff games did you have
i must at least say one no you do
chat is a police officer in florida if
you want to escape from shaq just jog
slowly away from him yes
and he'll fall eventually
who needs the most lotion my nomination
is for shaq and those ashy ankles
chicken flower before
[Applause]
that's
because that's because your mother had
to work last night
and i dropped her off i'm loving the uh
the weight adjustment that you guys had
to make with that table because of jack
shack and chuck that's a that's a
pretty fat ass check
kevin i could see that uh you know
jumanji must ain't do that well you got
the little ass diamonds on
[Laughter]
you couldn't come out of this pandemic
with a better suit option
i'm so sick of you and chucking these
awful suits y'all be wearing looking
like two weekends and i know shaq i know
you're world champ and i know you're
world champion but you're so big and
clumsy watching you play basketball like
watching a [ __ ] [ __ ]
[Applause]
come on let's hear it for shaq
thanks for being here and taking a break
from throwing barrels at super mario
please don't eat me shaq has shattered
eight backboards in 79 cervixes
has anybody ever seen shaq fall i see
this this is shaq he goes for a rebound
he doesn't get it oh no oh oh god no
he's just down there
check will go to the line
the slaves are stuck in the air it's the
worst thing ever nobody can help him up
because he's too big so you just gotta
wait
you gotta wait he's just there for a
while
it's like a it's like a turtle on the
highway
it's like
shoulders
but i've been doing shaq for so long i
can tell you exactly what he's thinking
right now
all my friends are saying mean things
hurt my feelings
shack a big strong man outside
what's off inside
shaq hate bullets
everyone is calling shaq dumb
i have a doctorate
charles is a dumb one
charles probably think dr rett is a girl
doctor
shaka boy doctor
shaq even you gotta admit your movies
are bad man
look at me all right stop making movies
now memorize that and repeat it to rick
fox
[Applause]
it goes back so i just let it grow up i
watched the show that night you look i
just want to say you look like a damn
idiot
there it was the other night you know
it doesn't look like hair to me
that looks like ernie's hair you're the
black ernie like you went to
did you see shank you got a chance to
saw his big behind in the back what is
shaq doing
since his retirement he he has nothing
to do he's in the most random places
well thank you
thank you very much yeah yeah i'm
serious i saw him like home depot two
weeks ago just but yeah he was helping
people like he wasn't even shopping he
was just helping people
put stuff in the car i'm shocked i don't
have nothing to do you want me to grab
it i'll help you
he has nothing to do with his time right
now
[Applause]
back you are gigantic
that suit is bigger than the one against
harvey weinstein
[Applause]
them
what are you doing what are you doing
streaking in the middle of the street
you going across the street in your
underwear yeah to see what
no i was swimming swimming where and
there's a pool in my office fool
okay i wish somebody hit your ass me too
i need somebody to run over there
look at shaq shaq shaq hasn't taken this
shirt off since high school okay that's
a true story that's a true stupid right
there
you've heard the term bomb before shaq
you played in phoenix we used to say
shaq's a bomb
[Laughter]
that was after i have four rings yeah i
know we didn't get you there we got you
at the end
uh 57 i said the same thing when you
played for the celtics jack's a bomb
[Laughter]
i said the same thing your whole career
okay
the only way to stop this is to bring in
the american express teammates
babe
shaq don't have no lips it's just gums
attached to his beard
[Laughter]
shaq got gums
tell you what i got the new baby uh car
baby seats for when she want to kiss
your little ass
why do you feel like you have to attack
my height shot you do know that you
weren't you're little because you're a
little man nobody's your size
size shoot for the celtics 36 36 why 36.
that's how many points you had like in a
month
all right uh cavaliers
33
why 33.
that's how many points you had in two
months
i don't need to tell my babies that you
said hi
you're a giant they hear you your voice
no they're not going through it
but i want them to see my face so they
can say hi
that'll scare him no it will not scare
him i i bet you i bet
your thousand dollars when i smile he
gonna smile better
all right
if my son cry if my son cry i want the
money we end up paying them i need you
i need little asap
zoe
say hi
hi
hi
hi my name is uncle jack say hi
you made
[Music]
it's okay son i know i got it yeah say
bye
[Music]
you'd be single
you wouldn't have all those kids that
you should kill them
[Applause]